Just one wild day.
Ooh Bro.
Cause you hit me with your
car and I didn't even want
I hit this man with my car.
I'm sorry. Pause everything. What's
up y'all okay? You always interrupted.
Yeah, I'm as a writer. This is John and
we've been a place in candy confession.
Oh yes. It's about to get real. You're
a little bit too close to my crotch.
Oh, hey bro. Hey Dude. I feel
like I'm in time out right now.
Isn't minutes I looked right.
How do you get to know each other?
We came out the same womb. That was
a lie. That's a lie. We came out,
I came up the womb of the sister-in-law
of his mother were cousins.
Yeah,
that was a very complicated
uh, yes or no. Pineapple is good on pizza.
I promise you if you kill you dog by now,
I don't understand why you
have trust issues like that.
You probably eat kit kats like without
breaking them apart. First of all,
I don't eat cake cats. I got Kevin,
he son Miss me with that Nigga.
He just had a rice crispy at Starbucks
on the right side of my mouth. But look,
this is what I'm trying to say.
Hmm. Pineapples is a fruit.
You Eat Cherries on your pizza? No.
Apple. Nah. Huh? How about water Malone?
If pizza sauce had all of
those, I would try it. It's
like a fruit pizza, right? Oh,
let me change your color for you.
You're doing the wrong thing. Oh Bro.
That's some pretty color though.
When you just like time, you feel me?
Like pineapple on my pizza, but I don't
want him to not be my friend no more.
So let me hit the,
never have I ever Friday while laugh,
Bro. Hey, what was in it right now?
You're just like,
cause I like, oh
hey. She says something. Oh Man.
I was like, hey. She was like,
Hey. And I was like, oh my God.
You laugh louder, right?
Yeah. It was like,
oh wait. Yes, Bro.
Oh Man, man, that was,
I just feel like farts has god gifts
God's gift saying like, Hey, it's okay.
I'm funny and power.
Never have I ever questioned
if I'll ever make it. Dude,
I was walking across the street
this morning. I was like,
I don't know if I got what it takes.
So yes, if I've questioned it,
no, I have not questioned it.
I'm going make it.
Wait,
I'm lying. You know what I'm
saying? I have, I've questioned it,
but cause it's hard, bro. It's a
lot of talented people in the world.
A lot of funny people. A
lot of cute. Yeah. People.
I'm not even the most talented and
I'm pretty ugly. But the thing is,
I think that like,
I think for the most part I got nothing.
I just really think I really, honestly,
you shouldn't beat yourself up about that,
bro, about being ugly or
being knocked down and you,
because you're both, no, I am.
I'm take courage.
You
pick up
yes or no.
I could beat you in a
street fight. Come on, Bro.
You don't want this dude
would win every fight we have.
I would win every fight. That's not
true. Look, it's about the heart.
You know what I'm saying? Now somebody's
saying no, it's about the fight, right?
Yeah,
but it's not,
I got hard you remembering that dumb
and dumber where he just reached in and
took homeboys heart. Oh, oh,
ever seeing King Kong? Nah. Yes, of
course. I started getting it bro.
You remember the part where my gene had
the dinosaur's mouth and he made his
mouth go like that.
That's not what I would do to you know,
but I thought I'd bring that up cause
I really liked that movie scene.
However it was for you would
lose that hands facing site.
We will let me catch you in the streets.
Just come in dressed
superman dude and I'm God
God, forgive me for that one. Never
have I ever divide my parents.
I think maybe both of us kind of like
deciding to follow our actual purpose and
not listen to our parents and everybody
else that was speaking logically to us.
Like to wake up and say for him to
be like, Yo, I want to be a rapper.
I wanted to pursue music full time. Or
for me to just wake up and be like, oh,
I want to be a youtuber full time.
I want to have businesses and
I want to be like an actor.
I want to be famous one day parents
don't see that and that doesn't make,
that doesn't make sense cause then
it's just like, it's not their fault,
it's just that they were
born in a different time.
I think a lot of parents don't realize
that we're born in a totally different
generation and all this stuff is possible
through like social media and stuff
like that.
You know,
I woke up yesterday and found my
face on the front of Apple Music,
one of the genres. I was like,
Oh snap, my face is right there.
You know what I'm saying? And it
brings you back to this. It's like, oh,
we can either aid the logical go to
school just like everybody else because
apparently it's like one in a
million people that makes this,
you know what I'm saying? That is able
to do this. But that's only half true.
If you put 100% in and you have people
that support you and let's be honest,
if you're, you're good at it, you're
talented at what you're doing,
then there's no reason for you to not
succeed unless you just do something
stupid. Yes sir. No, I'm done in
freestyle rap for you right now.
Don't ever let go even mean beat. All
right, let's get table. Yeah, it was,
yeah. Yeah. Okay. Josh, he did.
As a writer sitting at the table,
we're only talking about
the stories and you know,
it ain't no fables then his freestyle,
they just Duke and you know,
I can't remember at the time
I get on this, you know,
I'll be delighted to rec pool,
but I've got that green going to
get what you don't think. Glean.
I don't drink no name. What's
your, no, I'm leaving and you know,
funny and I've got the money,
but I don't get fine. Red Light,
green light and try to get them me.
But if I hit this Nigga yet,
it's going to be cleaned by, not a fair
fight, but I'm going to do it right. Yeah.
He said he gone take me like King Kong
but that ain't buys. Huh? Okay. Oh my bad.
You want it to keep in mind that I
thought I had more cause that was low key
whack to me and I wasn't
pleased with that.
They have are on days
and we have our off days.
And you going to say this was a on one
but yeah. Yours was low key clean though.
Never hired. Never have I ever
imagined. Yeah, we both came read
you that kid that nobody wants to be
called out. Like when they play popcorn,
the class, they never say
your name. Never have I ever
there, have I ever imagined
beating up a complete stranger?
I had a beat up a complete
stranger. No, I'm just kidding.
I got beat up by a complete stranger.
It's definitely cause I wasn't there.
That ain't that literally actually the
real reason bro. Come on. I got you bro.
Also, you would lose that
fight that we Nah. Ah, okay.
Well let me, the one thing that would
just make you say, that's enough.
We got to throw hands.
Ooh.
Honestly we throw hands on.
Yeah, but like real, real life.
Just like, look man, I'm like Loki
Authority type of stuff. Oh Bro. Okay.
First of all, I mean by you
looking I'm door, let's get
that out. But that's crazy.
But um, okay. Um, let me see.
I feel like I'm a very
level headed person.
Very whatever you do would have to be
repeated multiple times or like talk to be
wild. Okay. Just one thing I'm
saying just one wild day Bro.
Cause you hit me with your car and not
anything. I hate this man with my car.
I'm sorry. Pause everything.
How's everything?
I forgot I hit this barrier
with my cars on a snapchat too.
Like I was doing in
snapchat. He's like, Yo,
Mickey looked like you hit me with
your car cause I won't let them leave.
Look at Jackie van over here. He talking
about he gonna give you what you like,
who you go. Yeah, we get here.
I laid out in the backseat and we went
to the mall right now. I was like, Bruh,
I'm going die. He said my best
friend hit me with his car.
I was like, sorry, what up
guys? It's your boy Jason.
It's your boy, and thank you so
much for watching that video.
We love you and we're so
grateful. Yes, indeed.
We're so grateful and we want
do some great stuff. We're
going to start making three videos a
week, Wednesday, Fridays, and Sundays.
Oh my God,
300 you don't want to miss that.
Make sure you subscribe
by clicking that button.
We got our stuff for you to hear too.
So much goodness for everybody.
That's right, and we'll see you next
time. Thank you. Love you all. Please.